ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد الى ساعه
اخباريه جديده من العربيه نبداها بتطورات
المشهد السوداني نكملها مع جوله من
الملفات الدوليه ونبدا بابرز العناوين
تغيير تغيير خلينا بنقول بالوعي او بادراك
الطرفين لخطور المبعوثه للسوداني يؤكد
للعربيه ان طرف ادرك خطوره وضعها ويشدد
على ان الاولويه الان لوقف النار
مكثف للطيران الحربي فوق الخرطوم والشبكه
في بحر رغم تمديد الهدنه
الامم المتحده تحذر من تمدد ازمه السودان
لدول اخرى وتقول ان الوضع الانساني يتجه
لكارثه جميله
ومن ملفات هذه الساعه الاخباريه كذلك بعد
قليل
اجتماع عمان يؤكد اولويه الحل السياسي
لازمه سوريا ودعمها لبسط سيطرته على
اراضيها
ونحييكم مشاهدينا الى التفاصيل رغم قبولي
طرفي الصراع في السودان اي الجيش وقوه
الدعم السريع بتمديد الهدنه شهدت مناطق
وعده بالخرطوم وبحري مواجهات فيما دوه
انفجاراتهم في الخرطوم بالتزامن مع تحليق
مكثف للطيران الحربي الجانبين تبادل القصف
والاتهامات في مشهد يعيد الى الاذهان
الايام الاولى للمواجهات بعد هدوء
النسبيين في الايام القليله الماضيه الامم
المتحده تحدثت عن نزوح اكثر من 70 الف شخص
من السودان بسبب المواجهات وحظرت من
احتمال فرار نحو 800 الف اخرين ومع عوده
التصعيد اعلنت نقابه اطباء السودان ارتفاع
عدد قتل الاشتباكات الى
436 شخصا
لازم اشتغل يعني في ظروف لازم اشتغل على
السلع في زياده اي حاجه زايده لازم انا
اشتغل
لانه البلد ما امنه ما بقدر طبعا الوضع
بقى صعب اشوف الشعبي طبعا ما بيعرفوه
لازم
بنفسه يحاول يشتغل القواد ما حبابه والخوف
ما منه فايده
[موسيقى]
في حديثه خاص للعربيه قال المبعوث الامم
والى السودان قال ان العمل جار لوضع
التفاصيل
اللوجستيه لمفاوضات السودان مع الامريكيين
والسعوديين ورجعها ان تجري مفاوضاته الحل
في السعوديه مشيرا لان الاولويات الان هي
لوقف اطلاق النار واكد المبعوث الاممي ان
طرف ادرك خطوره الوضع ووافق على محادثات
فنيه للوصول لوقف اطلاق النار
تغيير خلينا منقول بالوعي او بادراك
الطرفين لخطور الوضع لانه وين بتعرف يعني
بالاسبوع الاول الاسبوع الثاني
فالجهتين كانوا
يعني كان يعبروا عن تاكيد انهم سينتسرون
على الجانب الثاني
فكانوا يطلبون باستسلام الجانب الثاني الى
اخره انا بتائده في ادراك اكثر حاليا انه
الانتساب العسكري غير ممكن
الا
للسعر
عالي جدا وهذا الدمار مدينه خاتوم ويمكن
فقدان كل البلد
وهذه مقابله حصريه لقناه العربيه والاكيد
باننا سنعود تفاصيل ما جاء في هذا اللقاء
المبعوثه الاممي كما تابعنا في هذا اللقاء
كان اتحدث عن موافقه الطرفين على البدء
بمفاوضات فنيه وتحدث عن امكانيه ان يكون
هناك فيما بعد مسار سياسي او على الاقل
خطه معينه للبدء ببناء مسار سياسي كما
نتابع اسفل الشاشه المبعوث الامم للسودان
العربيه يقول لا تنافس بين مبادره ايجاد
والمبادره السعوديه الامريكيه وهناك حديث
كذلك عن تقارب يمكن ان يحصل بين الطرفين
قال
المبعوثه الاممي الى السودان بان الطرفين
بحسب كلامه
تحدث عن وعيهما بخطوره هذه المرحله وهناك
شيء ربما يتم الاتفاق عليه ولكن سنعود لكل
هذا مشاهدينا اما بالمزيد من التفاصيل او
كذلك حتى بالنقاش قبل كل هذا
كانت هناك اتهامات متبادله اخرها اتهم من
خلالها الدعم السريع الجيش السوداني
بتحويل مستشفى السلاح الطبي باندرمان الى
منصه للقصف المدفعي واشار في بيان له الى
ان القصف المدفعي العشوائي في مستشفى
السلاح الطبي ادى لمقتل واصابتك كوادر
طبيه بحسب تاكيدات الدعم السريع واضاف
ايضا ان الطيران الجيش لا يزال يحلق في
سماء الخرطوم ويقصف احياء سكنيه
مشاهدينا قبل المتابعه
سنعود لهذه العواجل او ربما نعود لها بعد
قليل لنجملها كذلك ولكن في اخر تطورات كان
الجيش السوداني قد اكد في بيان له ان قوات
الدعم السريع حشدت اكثر من 65 الف عنصر
والفي مركبه للهجوم على الخرطوم قبل 15 من
ابريل لكن الجيش استطاع التصدي لمحاوله
انتشارهم مشيرا الى ان الجيش تمكن في غضون
اسبوعين من القتال ان يخفض قدرات الدعم
السريع القتاليه الى النصف مضيفا انه تم
احباط عده تحركات لتعزيزات عسكريه لقوات
الدعم السريع قادمه من اتجاه الغرب الى
الخرطومه
في المقابل كانت نشرات قوه الدعم السريع
لقطات فيديو تظهر انتشار عناصرها في مبنى
القصر الجمهوري وسط العاصمه الخرطوم وقالت
قوات الدعم السريع انها تسيطر تماما على
القصر الجمهوري وعلى محيطه في الخرطوم
بالاضافه الى مبنى الاذاعه والتلفزيون في
اندرمان كما اكد احد قاده الدعم السريع ان
سيطرتهم على القصر الجمهوري تاتي ضمن
مساعي الدعم السريع للحفاظ على ثروات
الشعب السوداني
قوات الدعم السريع من داخل القصر الجمهوري
نود ان نوصل رساله
لشعبنا الكريم ولشرفاء القوات المسلحه
اولا نناشد كل الشرفاء في قوات الشعب
المسلح بان هذا العمل الذي زدت فيه القوات
المسلحه هو عمل يخدم افراد واشخاص محددين
في القوات المسلحه والغرض الاساسي منه
النازل دارين السولو على سلطه الشعب
السوداني وعن طريق كوميتو نحن الان في
قوات الدعم السريع بالناشد كل القوات
المسلحه وشرفاء القوات المسلحه بانه نحن
ما عاد بالنسبه لهم وانما نحن نريد ان
نحافظ على سلطه الشعب ونقول للشعب
السوداني تواجد قوات الدعم السريع في داخل
القصر وفي كل ولايه الخرطوم القرض الاساسي
منه الحفاظ على سلطه الشعب
قال المتحدث باسم تجمع المهنيين
السودانيين امين ناصر مكي للعربيه قال ان
تجمع يسعى مع القوه السياسيه لحسن اطراف
المتنازعه للالتزام بالهدنه والوقف الدائم
لاطلاق النار هذا الوضع الانساني الانساني
الكارثي الذي يواجهه السودانيون
نامل ان ينتهي قريبا نحن لسنا محايدون نحن
ضد هذه الحرب جمله وتفصيل
نسعى في هذه الاثناء مع بقيه القوى
السياسيه بحث كل الاطراف المتقاتله سواء
في القوات المسلحه او في قوات الدعم
السريع بالالتزام بالهدنه
ووقف دائم لاطلاق النار
مشاهدينا قبل المتابعه نشير الى ما كنا
اوردناه في بدايه هذه الساعه الى تصريحات
مهمه عن المبعوث الاممي الى السودان
سنبقى مع هذه الصور المباشره من الخرطوم
هناك
يعني دخان يتصاعد وهناك كذلك اصوات
للشبكات كنا نستمع لها منذ قليل ولكن في
اخر هذه التطورات تصريحات ادلى بها مبعوث
الامم المتحده للسودان للعربيه يتحدث فيها
واكد على انه مفاوضات الحل في السودان
ستجري على الارجح في السعوديه المبعوث
الاممي للسودان كذلك قال الا تنافس بين
مبادرات ايجاد والمبادره السعوديه
الامريكيه تحدث عما يحدث الان من تطورات
وقال ان صوت رصاص اعلى من صوت العقل في
السودان حاليا وان هناك ادراك اكبر لدى
طرفي الازمه بضروره الحل كما المبعوث
الاممي للسودان بانه في هذا الوقت لا حديث
عن مفاوضات سياسيه بين طرفي الازمه ولكن
الحديث جاري بحسب قوله عن مفاوضات فنيه
كما اسماها لضمان وقف اطلاق النار اذا
فالكربيرت يقول بانه ليس هناك حديث عن
مفاوضات سياسيه حاليا بين الطرفي الازمه
اي بين الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع ولكن
هو يقول بان هناك مفاوضات اسمها مفاوضات
فنيه لضمان وقف اطلاق النار ربما سنتحدث
عن او النيه هي عن وقف اطلاق نار دائم
لاننا نحن الان مع محاوله تمديد هدى نتحدث
عن هدنه 72 ساعه الان تتخللها بعض
الاشتباكات من متابع على الشاشه ولكن
بيرتس يتحدث عن امكانيه ان يكون هناك
مفاوضات فنيه لضمان وقف اطلاق النار هذه
التصريحات ادلى بها المبعوث الاممي للس
همم يعني هناك اهتمام به لانه هناك عمليه
نزوح فدخل السوداني ولكن هناك ذلك موضوع
اللجوء المبعوث الاممي للسودان من خلال
هذا اللقاء مع العربيه قال ان الاولويه هي
لوقف اطلاق النار والسياسه ستاتي لاحقا
بحسب وصفه وكان تحدث منذ قليل وقال بانه
ليس هناك اطار فعلي او حقيقي لطرح خطه
سياسيه ولكن هناك خطه فنيه ستطرح اولا
لمحاوله يعني انهاء موضوع الاشتباكات
والاقتتال بصيغه دائمه او بطريقه دائمه
والموضوع الثاني هو فتح ممرات انسانيه
امنه قال كذلك المبعوثه الاممي للسودان
نبحث مع امريكا والسعوديه تفاصيل
اللوجستيه لهذه المفاوضات اذن الجهه
الاماميه تتحدث عن بحثها مع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وكذلك مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه تف اللوجستيه للمفاوضات
واكد بان طرفي الصراع تصور انهما قدران
على تحقيق النصر وقال بانه ستكون هناك
عوده لمساله الترتيبات السياسيه بعد تثبيت
وقف اطلاق النار سنعود لكل هذه التصريحات
سنعود لهذه المقابله مع المبعوثه الاممي
للسودان فولكربيتس والتي تحدث فيها عن
تطورات مهمه نعود لها بالنقاش وكذلك
بالتفاصيل لاحقا
اداره
الاعمال
الفنيه والوجستيكيه هلا مع الامريكان
والسعوديين فبطئت بالارجح
سيتم الارجح طبعا يعني الجانبين لازم ان
يوافقا على على هذا المكان
اذا مشاهدينا سنعود لهذه المقابله لاحقا
ولكن نذكر ببعض الملفات ذات الصله مع كل
هذه التطورات اخرها كانت خاصه بنقابه
الاطباء السودانيه التي اعلنت عن ارتفاع
عدد قتل الاشتباكات الدائره في البلاد الى
436 شخصا كما اكدت ان عدد المصابين ارتفعا
الى ما يزيد عن الالف والمائه شخص في صفوف
المدنيين نقابه الاطباء السودانيين قاره
ايضا ان هناك الكثير من الاصابات والوفيات
غير مشموله في هذا الحصر بسبب صعوبه
الوصول للمستشفيات مضيفه ان الاشتباكات
القبليه في مدينه الجنينه بولايه غرب
دافور اسفرت عن سقوط ارباع وتسعين قتيلا
مشيره الى ان جميع المستشفيات لا تعمل في
المدينه حتى اللحظه
ان تقريبا حوالي
جوا البناء وبرهوا على الكورنيش الناس
بتكون في الارض ارامل اطفال مسنين مرضى
احنا قاعدين في الارض ويعني اغلب الناس
قاعدين في الاراضي كلنا جايين اماكن بعيده
اغلبنا اتي من الخرطوم
وفي متابعه لعمليه الاجلال توافد المئات
من الرعايه الى ميناء بورتسودان ضمن عمليه
الاجلاء المستمره هربا من الاقتتال الدائر
نحن الان هنا في مدينه بورسودان بشرق
السودان سناخذ جوله لنتعرف على واقع هذا
المركز الرئيسي الذي يضم مئات من الاسر
الذي التي بدات في التوافق الى مدينه
بورسودان نبدا بالجهد الشعبي الذي يوازي
هذه الاعداد الكثيفه الان هيئه الموانئ
البحريه ممثله في غرفه الطوارئ عملت على
توفير هذا المستشفى المؤقت وهذه الغرفه
المؤقته للطوارئ للتعامل مع عدد من
الحالات التي قد ترد الى هذه المنطقه
حالات لسوريين وللسودانيين حتى تقدم لهم
الخدمات في هذا المركز الذي انشئ قبل
يومين في هذه المنطقه التي تضم ايضا كما
ذكرنا عددا من السوريين وعددا من اليمنيين
وايضا اضيفت اليهم نسبه اخرى من المقيمين
السودانيين الذين يحاولون ايضا عبر هذا
المركز ان ان يغادروا هذه المنصه هنا في
شرق السودان الى عدد من الدول عبر من
بورسودان
نتابعه مع التطورات من ام درمان صحفي في
مكتب العربيه في السودان شودي نادر جودي
اهلا بك معنا هل تغيرت الصوره منذ قليل
كنت تتحدث عن هدوء حذر عن توقف الاشتباكات
تقريبا في معظم الولايه مع تفرق لبعض
الاشتباكات في تخوم اندرمان لا حركه نزوح
تذكر الوضع باقن كما هو او هناك بعض
التطورات اضافيه
نعم الطيران الحربي ما يزال يحلق في سماء
مدينه الخرطوم هو عمليات تحليق بدات تؤمن
بمنتصف نهار اليوم لم تتوقف
حتى هذه اللحظه التي اتحدث فيها معكي هنا
هناك معكي هناك طائره تحلق في اجواء مدينه
ام درمان قصف استهدف عدد من المواقع جنوب
مدينه ام درمان مدينه الخرطوم بحري مدينه
شرق النيل وكذلك عده مواقع
بالخرطوم وهذا الدعم
قالت بان الجيش استهدفه الوحده الطبيه
التابعه لها في ضاحيه شنبات وقصفها ما قاد
الى رفوع
طلب
ات واصله على الجرح الذين كانوا يتلقون
العلاج داخل الوحده الطبيه تمه ادخن
للمنطقه الشرقيه هنا شرقي مدينه درمان في
مدينه الخرطوم البحري اصوات المضادات حتى
حتى هذه اللحظه تبدو مسموعه من عده
اتجاهات داخل مدينه
باصوات متقطعه نسمعها بالاسلحه الخفيفه من
اتجاه الجنوب
هذا التحليق من الطيران في سماء ام درمان
وقصف الطائرات لبعض المراكز كما تتحدث
ولكن الصوره من ورائك تشير الى ان الحياه
تبدو شبه عاديه صحيح هناك حركه تنقل عاديه
من السيارات من الدرجات الناريه من المشاه
كذلك لا نعلم ان كانت المحلات المغازات
التجاريه مثلا عادت الى العمل بطريقه
عاديه البقالات الصغيره كذلك التي كانت
موجوده ومفتوحه للعموم في ظل اغلاق بعض
المغازات الكبرى عادت الى العمل كيف هي
صوره من هذه الناحيه
نعم كثير جدا
وامس مباشره عملها بعضها مباشره بشكل شبه
كلي محلات البقالات والمحلات الصغيره هذه
استسلمت مبكرا نفدا ما لديها من مواد
وسيله تموينيه ولكن هناك محل كبرى ما تزال
هي
[موسيقى]
الى حد بشكل
هناك شح في الوقود لو كنت تشاهدين خلفي
اصداف لسيارات منذ صباح منذ صباح الباكر
من اجل الحصول على الوقود محطات الوقود لم
تعمل جميعها حتى هذه اللحظه
التي
تعمل مخمات لازال تعمل
بشكل ابوابها طوال اليوم
الصوره هنا في مدينه ام درمان ربما هي
افضل من الخرطوم بحري وكذلك مدينه الخرطوم
بدات
الخدمات الاساسيه وفي الوقود وخلافه شكرا
جزيلا لك شهوتي نادر الصحفي في مكتب
العربيه كنت معنا من اندرمان
ونتابع دائما ولكن هذه المره من الخرطوم
مع زميلنا سالم الهاشم سالم اهلا بك معنا
سالم الصوره من الخرطوم كنا منذ قليل مع
صور مباشره في الواقع وكنا نتابع دخان
يتصاعد على فكره هذه الصوره منذ بدايه
الاشتباكات لم تختلف كثيرا يعني تذهب
ولكنها تعود دخان يتصاعد هذه هي الصوره
التي نتحدث عنها والشبكات متفرقه رغم
الهودن رغم الاعلان عن امكانيه ان يطرح
شيء يقلل من الاقتتال ولكن هذه الصوره
تبقى ثابته تقريبا منذ بدايه الاشتباكات
نتحدث عن الشبكات باستعمال الاسلحه ثقيله
سالم كيف هو الوضع
نعم تجددت الاشتباكات منذ منتصف نهار
اليوم كان ابرزها او في بدايتها كانت في
مدينه بحري في المنطقه الصناعيه كانت
هنالك اشتباكات عنيفه وكان هنالك قصف
بالطائرات في كافور مربع سته وهو في وسط
مدينه بحري وبالقرب من المنطقه الصناعيه
وهي هذه اعمده الدخان التي ترينها على
الشاشه
هذه المنطقه كانت بها او بها يوجد بها مقر
من مقر قوات الدعم السريع يضاف الى ذلك
بعدها بساعه وساعه ونصف تجددت الاشتباكات
وبدات تحلق الطائرات في مناطق متفرقه من
العاصمه الخرطوم هنا اقصد مدينه الخرطوم
في المكان الذي نقف فيه هو اقصى شرقي
الخرطوم من هنا راينا قصفا كان في محيط
مطار الخرطوم الدولي وفي محيط القياده
العامه للجيش وهي ايضا اماكن تتمركز بها
قوات الدعم السريع وكان الجيش السوداني قد
اكد ان القوات الجويه السودانيه تستهدف
الاماكن التي تتمركز بها قوات الدعم
السريع ومقر كذلك قوات الدعم السريع
هذه
هذه الاشتباكات وهذا القصف ومضادات
الطائرات التي استمعنا اليها استمرت منذ
عصر اليوم وحتى هذه اللحظات الان نحن على
وشك مغيب الشمس او بالفعل هي قد غابت
الشمس الان
واعمده الدخان تحيط بمدينه الخرطوم جراء
هذا القصف وهذه الاشتباكات وهي ربما يعني
هجمه تقوم بها القوات الجويه السودانيه
مستهدفه قوات الدعم السريعه التي قال
الجيش السوداني انها قوات متمرده
سريعه التقليديه ام انها تتمركز في نقاط
اخرى هناك من يتحدث عن تمركزها في مستشفى
مثلا الدعم السريع نفذ ذلك بشده ولكن اين
تتمركز سالم
نعم كما ذكرتي وذكر الجيش السوداني كذلك
انها تتمركز في داخل المستشفيات وتتخذ من
هذه المستشفيات مقر للعمليات هذا وصف
الجيش السوداني به قوات الدعم السريع نحن
الان وانا اتحدث لكي نستمع الى اصوات نعم
صحيح نحن الان نستمع الى اصوات مضادات
الطائرات في هذه المنطقه التي هي من خلف
الان هذه المنطقه هي المدينه الرياضيه
وفيها واحد من مقر قوات الدعم السريع بل
انه الكثير من المراقبين يرون والمتابعين
لهذا المشهد ان الطلقه الاولى التي انطلقت
في هذه
الحرب بدات من هنا من المدينه الرياضيه في
منطقه الخرطوم اقصى جنوب شارع المطار ربما
ايضا هنا ايضا توجد قوات للدعم السريع في
هذه المنطقه ولديها مضادات طائرات ونستمع
الى ازيزا الطائرات ما زال الان يحلق في
سماء الخرطوم المقر التي تستهدفها هي مقر
الدعم السريع وكذلك المناطق التي تتمركز
بها قوات الدعم السريع ونحن نعلم ان قوات
الدعم السريع اتخذت من بعض المناطق
ارتكازات ومناطق تجلس بهذه القوات وتتمركز
فيها وتتمدرس فيها ربما هذا هو المقصود من
هذه الهجمه التي تقودها القوات الجويه
السودانيه
نحن امام تصريحات سالم ادلى بها المبعوث
الاممي للسودان هناك حديث عن امكانيه ان
تكون هناك مفاوضات فنيه لضمان وقف دائم
لاطلاق النار لا نعلم ان كان هذا الكلام
وهي تصريحات اتت في مقابله خاصه للعربيه
مع المبعوثه الاممي للسودان لا نعلم ان
كان هذا الكلام يمكن ان يتجلى بشكل او
باخر على الارض بمعنى انه هل مثلا تغير
تمركز بعض القوات هل انسحبت من بعض
الاماكن هل هناك ترتيبات مغايره لما
شاهدناه في الايام السابقه يمكن ان يؤكد
هذا التوجه الذي قد يقول عنه مراقبون بانه
ايجابي
نعم هو توجه ايجابي بالفعل سياسيا لكنه
على الارض غير موجود حتى هذه اللحظه بدليل
اننا نحن الان ونتحدث عن مواطني ولايه
الخرطوم هم فيها لعو وتوتر منذ اكثر من
اربع ساعات حتى الان من تواصل القصف تواصل
مضادات الطائرات وتواصل استماع للمدافع
الثقيله والخفيفه فهنا يصعب الحديث عن مثل
هذه الامور ونحن نستمع الاصوات الرصاص وهي
مرتفعه تماما مضادات الطائرات كذلك القصف
كل هذه الامور وهناك حديث عن هدنه كذلك ان
هذه الهدنه قد انطلقت وانها قد بدات وهي
لايقاف تبادل اطلاق النار لكن على الارض
كل هذا غير موجود طيب سنعود لك في كل
الحالات لمتابعه اكثر تفاصيل هذا الصوره
التي ذكرنا بانها صوره مباشره من الخرطوم
مع استمرار الشبكات رقم هذه الهدنه ورغم
هذا التصريحات اعود لك في قادمه انا نشرات
سلمى الهاشمي مراسل العربيه من الخرطوم
شكرا لك
في اخر تطورات كذلك كان حذرا مدير الاعلام
لدى اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر في
السودان من ان الاوضاع الانسانيه سيئه جدا
وهناك كوارث عديده الامر الذي يدفع
بالصليب الاحمر الى التركيز على القطاع
الصحي لايصال المساعدات الطبيه
الاوضاع الانسانيه سيئه جدا وهناك كوارث
الاولويه القصوى بالنسبه للصليب الاحمر هي
القطاع الصحي حيث تعاني المستشفيات من عدم
توفر المياه والكهرباء وانها غير قادره
على العمل لذلك المستشفيات بحاجه الى
مساعدات طبيه كبيره جدا وعلينا البدء
بتقديم الدعم المطلوب وتوفير المستلزمات
الطبيه واللقاحات اللازمه
وكان اعلن مسؤول اللاجئين في الامم
المتحده توقعاته بفرار ما يفوق عن الثمان
مئه الف شخص من السودان اثر النزاع في
البلاد كما اضاف المسؤول ان ثلاثه وسبعين
الف شخص فرو متجهين الى دول الجوار وفي
السياق ذاته عبر مناسق الامم المتحده
لشؤون الانسانيه عن مخاوفه من امتداد ازمه
السودان الى دول الجوار واعلن المناسق ان
الوضع الانسانيه في البلاد يتجه الى كارثه
وان شحنه من الادويه عالقه على الحدود ولم
تدخل السودان بعد
مشاهدينا يواجه السودانيون خطر المواجهات
العسكريه بين الجيش وقوه الدعم السريع
الدائره منذ ثلاثه اسابيع وعلى الرغم من
الاوضاع الامنيه المترديه يضطر كثيرون الى
التوجه الى اعمالهم ووظائفهم المختلفه
لاعاله اسرهم في ظل اوضاع اقتصاديه
وانسانيه صعبه نتابع
لازم اشتغل يعني في الظروف
يعني سلع زاد في زياده ويعني اي حاجه
زايده لازم انا اشتغل يعني
زي ساعتين ثلاثه وقف لانه البلد ما امنه
ما في يعني اي حاجه
هذا ويواجه ثلث سكان السودان البالغ عددهم
حوالي 45 مليون نسمه يواجهون ازمه جوع
متصاعده ما دفع برنامج الاغذيه العالمي
لوصف الوضع الانساني في البلاد بالكارثه
معاناه على معاناه تجثم على قلوب
السودانيين اما كساد يؤرق محلهم التجاريه
او شبح جوع يلوح في الافق السودان يشكو
ازمه تتراكم عليها ازمات سابقه متداخله
الوضع الانساني كارثي او كما وصفه الامين
العام للامم المتحده بلغ نقطه الانهيار
السودان اسره على السلطه في السودان لا
يعرض مستقبل هذا البلد للخطر فحسب انه
يضيء فتيلا يمكن ان ينفجر عبر الحدود
ويسبب معاناه هائله لسنوات ويعيد التنميه
الى الوراء لعقود
صراع فاقم معاناه المدنيين الساعين وراء
لقمه العيش تقرير اممي سابق اوضح ان ثلث
السكان اصلا كانوا يعيشون على المساعدات
الانسانيه قبل اندلاع الصراع ووفق برنامج
الاغذيه العالمي يواجه 15 مليون شخص
انعداما حادا في الامن الغذائي وما عندي
لاعب الصراع باتت ولايات السودان الثمانيه
عشره تحت رحمه مساعدات قد تتوقف بسبب
اغلاق ممرات الاغاثه حيث تمثل دارفور
التحدي الاكبر من الناحيه الانسانيه بحسب
المنظمات الامميه وتليها عده ولايات هي
الاكثر تضررا من النزاع والتدهور
الاقتصادي كالخرطوم وكسلا والنيل الابيض
وجنوب كردفان لا طعام لملايين الاطفال
تصريح سبق صراع السلطه لمسؤوله الاتصال في
برنامج الاغذيه العالمي في السودان ومع
اول مواجهات اندلعت فان ارقام الذين
سينامون جائعين قد تتضاعف محمد السيف
العربيه
نناقش هذه التطورات مع ضيفنا من الخرطوم
مصطفى ادم احمد مدير منظمه الزرقاء
للتنميه سيد مصطفى اهلا بك معنا قبل البدء
بتحليل التطورات في اداخل السوداني سيد
مصطفى ان كنت تسمعني اسمح لي ان انقل لك
بعض المعلومات الخاصه بتصريحات المبعوث
الاممي هو يتحدث عن سعي لامكانيه ان تكون
هناك مفاوضات فنيه اولا لطرح خطه معينه في
المرحله القادمه تكون السياسيه ولكن الاهم
لتثبيت شكل معين من اشكال الاتفاق على
مرات انسانيه يتم تامينها وتتم مراقبتها
كذلك ما رايك في هذه التصريحات هل الوضع
ملائم قد يدفع قد يشجع على طرح كهذا في
هذا التوقيت
سيد مصطفى
طيب يبدو باننا فقدنا الاتصال بمصطفى ادم
احمد سيد مصطفى هل تسمعني يبدو بان ضيفي
لا يسمعني نعود له بعد قليل ربما لمحاوله
قراءه لهذا التصريحات ولكن سنستمر مع بعض
الاخبار ذات ومع استمرار المعارك مشاهدينا
في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم تزداد
الاوضاع المعيشيه سوءا يوما بعد يوم هذه
قصه عائله اضطرت الى ترك منزلها بعد
انقطاع الماء والكهرباء والعيش على وجبه
طعام واحده في اليوم متابع
من نافذه غرفه صغيره تراقب هبه شوارع
مدينه غاب عنها الامن والسلام منذ اسابيع
خرجت مع عائلتها الصغيره من منزلهم في
الخرطوم بعد انقطاع الماء والكهرباء جراء
القتال
لتستاجر العائله غرفه فوق سطح مبنى في
منطقه اخرى من العاصمه لعلها تجد فيها بعض
الامان وابسط اساسيات الحياه
لكن صوت ضربات المدفعيه والطيران والرصاص
كان مصاحبا لهم كيف لا وهذا هو الحال في
الخرطوم كلها منذ اندلاع الصراع اصوات انا
كل يوم بسمعها
مرعبه شديد يعني بخاف على ناس البيت بخاف
على نفسي
بتمتمات ودعوات تصلي لوالده هبه من اجل
ابنائها ومن اجل وطن غادره الامن
والاستقرار وعمت فيه الفوضى ولا يعرف ما
ينتظره ان شاء الله ربنا يعني يدي العافيه
والناس تبقى كلها طيبه الوضع يرجع لوضع
الطبيعي ونرجع بيوتنا لانه طولنا بالجنه
من بيوتنا الكهرباء قاطعه على حد
الدعامه قاعدين قدام بيتنا
ما دارين يزح وما راضيين ان نصلح العمود
بتاع الكهرباء طبعا الكهرباء ما في مويه
ما في عشان كذا انا مرقنا البيوت
قلق العائله الصغيره وخوفها ليس من وابل
القذائف والرصاص فحسب بل تخشى ايضا من
انقطاع الامدادات الغذائيه فلجات الى حياه
الكفاف
غذائيه
كل الدكاكين مقفوله والموجوده باسعار
غاليه شديد بنحاول ناكل اكل قدره حد
الكفاف يعني بناكل وجبه عشان تكفينا باقي
المواد الموجوده لليوم البعديه لانهم
معروف قصه من بين الاف القصص لاسر تكافح
في الخرطوم وتبحث عن ابسط حقوقها حق العيش
في سلم وسكينه وسلام وربنا يصلح الحال
ويرجح على السودان احسن من اول بكثير ملوك
الشيخ العربي
مشاهدينا قبل المتابعه نشير الى هذا
العاجل الان رئيس كينيا يقول بان طرفي
الصراع بالسودان رفض الاستجابه لدعواته
وقفي اطلاق النار كما نتابع اسفل الشاشه
رئيس كينيا يقول ان طرف الصرع بالسودان اي
دعم سريع والجيش السوداني رفض الاستجابه
لدعوه وقف اطلاق النار نتحدث عن مفروض
هدنه في هذه الاوقات هدنه انطلقت نظم
منتصف ليل الامس مستمره الاثنين وسبعين
ساعه اتفق مبدئيا الطرفان على الالتزام
بها ولكن هذه الهدنه مثل سابقاتها تخللتها
بعض الاشتباكات كذلك هذا التصريح لرئيس
كينيا ياتي موازاه مع بعض تصريحات الاخرى
لفولكر بيرتز المبعوث الاممي الى السودان
والذي كان تحدث بان هناك شبه اتفاق بين
الطرفين الدعم والجيش على البدء بت رتيب
خطه لمفاوضات فنيه كما اسماها ليست سياسيه
فنيه بالاساس
الهدف منها هي اولا ان يكون هناك بعد
سياسي لهذه الخطه يعني ان يتم ترتيب شيء
سياسي بعد المفاوضات الفنيه وخاصه ان يتم
تامين ممرات امنه وان
تقوم الجهه الامميه
بمتابعه بمراقبه هذه
الممرات
نعود الى هذه التصريحات في لقائه مع
العربيه كان اكدان مبعوث الاممي فولكر
بيرتس اكد ان طرفي النزاع في السودان بات
يدركان كما ذكرنا منذ قليل ان الانتصار
العسكري لن يكون الا بثمن باهظ على
السودان لاحظنا
في الاسبوع الاخير تقريبا تغيير
بلهجه ويمكن تغيير تغيير خلينا بنقول
بالوعي او بادراك الطرفين لخطور الوضع
لانه وين بتعرف يعني بالاسبوع الاول
الاسبوع الثاني
فالجهتين كانوا
يعني كانوا يعبروا ان تاكيد انهم سيمتصرون
على الجانب الثاني
كانوا يطلبون باستسلام الجانب الثاني الى
اخره انا بتائده في ادراك اكثر حاليا انه
الانتصار العسكري غير ممكن
الا للسعر
عالي جدا
نعود لنناقش كل هذه التطورات الى ضيفنا من
جديد من الخرطوم مصطفى ادم احمد مدير
منظمه الزرقاء للتنميه سيد مصطفى هل
تسمعني
اهلا وسهلا بك سيد مصطفى المبعوث الاممي
للسودان كان تحدث عن امكانيه امكانيه نقول
طبعا ان يكون هناك اتفاق على مفاوضات فنيه
تؤمن لمسارات تراقبها الامم المتحده الى
اي مدى ما يحدث الان من تطورات هو مبدئيا
يهيئ لهكذا خطه ولهكذا مفاوضات فنيه بحسب
قراءتك
[موسيقى]
عديده فربما هناك
اتفاق على شبه النقاط ستعتمد في الايام
القادمه لا نعلم
السيد المبعوث يكون اكثر وضوحا هو مبعوث
امميه عنده
مفهوم وهو معني بفتره الانتقال الديمقراطي
والان اللي هو اصبح في مخب الريح الان
احنا
في صراع دموي ودمار الشامل في الدوله
السودانيه لابد ان رؤيه جديده
الان مطالبا لابد من رؤيه جديده كله الرؤى
القديمه هي النتيجه بتاعتها هي هذه الحرب
يعني نحن من فتره الانتقال من بعد ثوره
ديسمبر يعني كل المحاولات لفتره
اكتوبر الان وصلنا لهذه لابد من رؤيه
جديده وقويه وشام يعني
لتحدد استقرار الدوله السودانيه
انتقال ديمقراطي ضروريه جديده دي الان
اصطدمت اصطدمت هي بواقع مريض جدا وانسجه
هذه الحربه الثانيه الان بنعيش يعني
لا بد له من رؤيه جديده الرؤيه جديده
يعني كان هناك بث لهذه التصريحات اما من
خلال العواجل او كذلك حتى من خلال بعض
المقتطفات من هذا اللقاء هو تحدث
بتفصيل يعني تحدث عن الجانبين تحدث عن هذه
المفاوضات الفنيه التي ستؤسس لمفاضات
السياسيه ولكن سنعود لها لاحقا سيد مصطفى
اسمح لي ان اكتفي معك حتى الان بهذا القدر
على ان تتوضح صوره اكثر نناقش هذه النقاط
في وقت لاحق واشكرك جزيل الشكر على كل ما
تفضلت به من الخرطوم مصطفى ادم احمد مدير
منظمه الزرقاء للتنميه شكرا جزيلا لك
سنناقش هذه النقاط او نحاول فهمها كذلك مع
ضيفنا من القاهره عادل سيد احمد الصحفي
السوداني سيد عادل اهلا بك معنا كنا نتحدث
في نشره سابقه تحدثت مع حضرتك عن ضروره ان
يكون هناك التزام لفتح ممرات امنه وكان
بيتس استمع لنا في الواقع لانه اتت
تصريحات بعد دقائق في لقاء مع العربيه هو
تحدث عن ضروره ان يتم ذلك سيد عادل وقال
بان هناك خطه لمفاوضات فنيه هل تعتقد بانه
المرحله هي مرحله قد تساعد لامكانيه ان
تطرح مثل هكذا مبادرات
مساء الخير على كل مشاهدي العربيه حقيقه
المطلوبه الان
من الهدنه
فتح مسارات لتحقيق تقدم في الجوانب
المعطله المتعلقه بالجانب الغذائي والجانب
الامني والجانب الطبي انا اعتقد انه هذه
الخطوه لابد منها لذلك فان الاتجاه الى
الهدنه لتحقيق هذا الجانب انا اعتقد انه
سيحقق خطوه مطلوبه في الاتجاه الايجابي
كذلك ميزه الهدنه واخف اطلاق النار ستساعد
كثيرا على ما يمكن ان نسميه يعني نشوء او
ظهور اشارات للثقه بين الطرفين تمكن
الطرفان من الجلوس على مائده واحده حتى
ولو كانت على مراحل فان هذا ايضا
مهمه هذه النقطه اللي حضرتك تطرحها وهي
نقطه الثقه المتبادله بين طرفين وعلى فكره
المبعوث الاممي للسودان في كان تحدث كذلك
على وجوب ان يكون هناك تفاهم مشترك حول
شروط امكانيه ان تكون هدنه هل يمكن ان
نستعيد ثقه ولو جزئيا كما تفضلت حضرتك
بالاشاره ثقه متبادله بين الطرفين على
الاقل الدفع بمسار تفاوضي فني او سياسي
فيما بعد
احمد صحفي السوداني
والله هذا يعني شعور لا يوصف ان الواحد
يكون كله يعني هو
بامان الناس كتير هناك عندها مشاكل ما
قادره ما عندها فلوس ما عندها مصاري ناس
كتير معلقه نحمد الله سبحانه والشكر لاهل
المملكه هل هذا الاستحمام
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات